announce
um uh to introduce Our Guest who is uh I
won't say old friend I'll say a long
time and colleague of mine from the
informatics world so so those of you who
are trainees you know this will be you
guys in like 20 30 years
um right we won't Revenue this Old Navy
Award stories or anything anyways I'm
pleased to announce uh pleased to
introduce Dr Danny Sands
um from Boston Massachusetts
who is a um primary care internist at
Beth Israel Deaconess Medical Center and
also has an academic appointment at
Harvard Medical School he
um is a tried and true informatician he
um makes extensive use of Health I.T in
his practice and in addition to
practicing he's currently the chief
medical officer of I don't know how to
pronounce it Wicked smart it's not okay
and he's also cope founder of and chief
advocacy officer for the society for
participating medicine which is why he
is in town
um organizing
um an event tomorrow that D mice is a
co-sponsor of
um and uh there's still tickets
available if anyone wants to go it's a
very cool event
um
and it takes place tomorrow from 8 A.M
to 1 p.m and will
um be
um What's the title of it I have it on
here somewhere advancing Health Equity
through participatory medicine great
anyway so just uh just to not take too
much of Dr Sam's time he is originally a
graduate of Brown University where he
got a Bachelor of Science in biology and
Medicine in 1984 attended the Ohio State
College of Medicine graduating in 1988
did a residency at Boston City Hospital
in Internal Medicine and then an mph at
the Harvard t.h Chan School of Public
Health and
um has done a number of things that I
won't continue to read on because I
don't want to take too much time of his
talk all right thank you very much bill
so I got a question am I do I have to be
in front of this webcam in order to be
projected yeah they're just they're just
viewing your slides that's good and and
here's another way to make that bigger
so we don't have those people across the
top no that's the WebEx that's just you
have to do it yeah all right and this is
the microphone that picks you up right
here you can stand over there will it
pick me will it pick me up okay yeah
yeah it picks you up yeah okay and can
we is it possible to make the lights a
little brighter brighter is that okay or
is that going to be too hard for you to
see it depends
it is it's too hard to see yeah okay
okay we'll be more dark but if you've
fallen asleep it will come get you no
I'm just kidding okay it just feels dark
um all right so thanks for uh for coming
today and for those of you on WebEx I
appreciate you coming virtually
um I've entitled this talk uh that the
future of healthcare is participatory
and and it's about the importance of
informatics as a supporting role and
this is what I want you to take away
from this when we finish okay
so let me start by saying something well
let me ask you a question I can't see
the hands of people who are remote but
but of you here how many of you are
clinicians Healthcare Professionals in
some way okay so a couple of you yeah
all right and do you still see patients
yeah good what's your area
all right now I'm seeing the ALS
patients from mental health support but
I did Internal Medicine Psychiatry wow
yeah less patience yeah
wow okay that's interesting and Bill I
know about you
um so um so I want to just point out
some of the challenges we have with our
Health Care system can I just get a do
we is there a way to get feedback from
the people I want to make sure they can
hear me over there yeah
good okay good so um so I want to point
out that we have a crisis of Health Care
in this country in the world globally
but particularly in this country
although as I travel the world many of
these things uh persist so some of these
things are epidemic of uh chronic
diseases and aging population everywhere
in the world uh patients uh with Rising
expectations as not just patients but as
actually Healthcare consumers as we say
which is a stupid word uh Rising costs
uh you know in the U.S we send over a
fifth of our GDP on health care and we
are proud to have the 35th best
Healthcare country in the best system in
the world uh for that and we have an
increased complexity with our system not
just on the medical side but on the
transition side we have an increasing
number of hands that touch patients
um we have poor information exchange
coordination of care and we have a lack
of trust in declining patient
satisfaction and I'm only listing a few
of the things that affect our Health
Care Systems
but we still think about health care as
if it is a traditional service industry
this is the way economists talk about it
this is the way almost everybody talks
about it somehow so so this
is a problem because it is not just a
typical service if we think about it as
a typical service we're going to do it
in Injustice
idea ideally what should patient care be
and I would say to you that Health Care
should be thought of as a collaboration
a collaboration around the patient's
health
and that idea of of that Healthcare is a
collaboration and by the way we talk
about collaborations in healthcare all
the time but it's usually about teamwork
and about you know how the nurses and
the doctors and techs and everybody talk
to each other but but it's more than
that it's a collaboration between the
patient and the healthcare professional
and collaboration applied to Health Care
is participatory medicine
now
how many of you collaborate in any
aspect of your lives
everybody knows right I mean you're
either collaborating with people here in
the department about research or it
might be a uh you know a grant that
you're doing it might be uh raising
children it might be other various
things all kinds of things we
collaborate around
so from as Bill said my many many years
of experience I will tell you that I
think there are five features that are
common to successful collaborations and
before I go on I should mention at least
this picture is really a patient of mine
but he's also a collaborator
um and we are I'll mention again later
this is e-patient Dave you can actually
read more about him online uh so that
really is the office where I take care
of them notice the antique computer
screen we have there we still have those
anti-computer screens in our offices
it's a nightmare but anyhow
um so successful collaboration that's
what I was getting to so the first thing
is open communication
critical so you know you know I
we've all heard uh you're not
communicating uh you're not
communicating with me you've got to tell
me what's on your mind so that's one
thing another thing is
Sue decisions that you're
picture a third thing is mutual respect
and Trust
next there's information sharing and
finally engagement okay it's engaging in
the conversation the discussion the
collaboration
so those are five of the elements of
successful collaboration I I would
submit to you
um and and let's think about uh you know
how we could apply these to Health Care
but let's take a check
check digression for just a minute okay
this is some data showing the rising use
of the internet across different
demographic groups and I'm sorry in this
the way this is projecting you can't
read it that well but I'm going to
orient you we're looking at the years
2000 out to 2021.
and the the top bar there that starts at
about 70 and now it's at almost 100
percent that's people 18 to 29. no
surprise right all these people are
online but what's I think more
interesting is the bottom line which are
people 65 and up where now we have
almost 70 percent of these people online
and so that's a really important thing
to keep in mind the point is is this
cutting across all uh demographic groups
and and by the way if we look at this
sort of sliced by um
uh by race or ethnicity and so on that's
Rising too and although back when you
know 20 years ago we were talking about
oh it's the Broadband access that's the
big problem it's causing the digital
divide it's not so much anymore because
these devices these handheld devices
that we're carrying has helped have
helped us LeapFrog the digital divide in
many situations we still have a digital
guide don't get me wrong but it's uh
it's getting less and this is happening
all over the world by the way
so the fact that we all have access to
this information is fantastic because
this is allowing
people patients specifically to connect
to information to caregivers to health
care and to each other
and that has been quite dramatic and
that in fact has enabled so many of the
things that you are working on and that
that we'll be talking about today
so this enables your world okay not just
for research but your world right so
think about your world think about the
world we live in
and and think about I don't know I'm not
going to ask you hello teacher if you
our interview is but but uh it is
interesting to you know the acceleration
of Technology right and and how things
have changed I can tell you that uh I
remember when my oldest daughter was two
years old and I showed her I don't
remember these times right I showed her
I had this BlackBerry device and all of
a sudden the Blackberry could not just
do email but it couldn't connect to the
web
right and that was just magical right
this is like 1995.
and and I I thought this was amazing
because the things there's no wires
right there's no wires I got this thing
and it connects everywhere I can get the
world's information on it and I showed
it to my two-year-old daughter
and she said
nah it's too slow
just two
anyhow think about what's happened to
the world technologically right this is
the world we live in
okay you got an Apple product you got a
a PC right Airbnb amazon.com when I'm
speaking of conferences uh sometimes
I'll ask I'll say
Amazon right what other service in the
U.S at least can can can just almost
know exactly what it is that you need
and have it delivered to your door
within a couple of days or even the next
day even the same day
but it's you know but but it's so
permeated our lives so this is what I
ask at conferences I say well how many
of you have ordered something on Amazon
through this conference while you were
sitting in the conference and you know
half the people's hands go up because
you think of something and if you make
it happen so this is how our
expectations have changed okay I mean
nobody even thinks about taking a taxi
anymore right we're taking Uber and left
all the time it's it's just a magical
thing so is this how you experience
Health Care
when you're in the Health Care system as
a patient or as a caregiver
I would argue that it's not that we're
not there yet
so let's talk a little bit about the
online habits of U.S adults I'll just
give you a few facts and and admittedly
some of these are a little out of date
but they're still uh I think they're
still valid because they I was tracking
them and they get higher and higher all
the time so here eighty percent of
online adults have looked for health
information online eighty percent and
each day more people search for health
information than see one of us
okay that's remarkable
okay that's really remarkable and more
than half of those people act on the
information they're finding online
okay and that's really interesting too
because
when it comes to information that we
tell patients how many you know what
proportion of the time do they act on
the information that we give them
you know it's it's a low percent maybe
not a fair comparison but I think just
to to put things in perspective okay
patients don't often do what we ask them
to do in the office
a third read about other health others
Health experience online
um
I'll just go into this a quarter have
tracked their own health information
online how many of you have tracked your
health information online
we all have actually because if you look
one of these devices and sort of by
default your information is being
tracked online you can choose to share
it with other people or not and people
are using social media for health so
these are really dramatic things and
this is how people think about health
and and the uh the internet
so there's this term that that I use
that we we use people use called
e-patients
and so back a long time ago uh at the
dawn of the internet when we realized
that there are all these opportunities
for patients to use the internet for
health information
um everything was e
okay we talked about the work we did as
e-health for example but the E for that
is electronic
but the e-patient benefits from the
online Technologies but the E here is
about engagement
and the term e-patients came from a
colleague and friend a deceased now Tom
Ferguson who was the guy who Inspira you
know who brought a bunch of people
together who were trying to make Health
Care different building on these
Technologies and this is the group that
ultimately uh created the society for
participatory medicine
and he defined the patients and he said
e-patients are engaged equipped
empowered educated and enlightened okay
so that's what e-patients are about it's
not electronic electronic is just a it's
one of the uh the layers of the network
let's say
um so that's what it's about so how can
we Foster collaboration with patients I
would say there are three areas that I
want to focus on today
um as we talk about this so it's
information convenience and
communication and all of that is so that
e-patients can play a greater role in
their care
and in my mind you may say well not
everybody's an e-patient yes I say
everybody is not an e patient however
you're either an e-patient or you need
to become an impatient you will become
impatient hopefully everybody's going to
be in some uh some level of transition
to that role
so let's talk briefly about information
I'd say there are three types of
information I'm going to talk
okay type one information
general information it's in let's talk
about diabetes okay if what is diabetes
what happens in diabetes how do people
get sick with it why do people get sick
with it uh how do we follow it what are
the complications and so on that's type
one information
type 2 information is information about
my disease I want to know what's going
on with my diabetes
what's 1911 A1C what's my uh you know am
I having protein in my urine uh what is
what are doctors saying about me this is
my record information
okay so that's what that is Type 3
information is peer information and
support it's information about other
people like me other people who have
diabetes and what have been their
experiences and what can they add and
these are orthogonal to one another
they're very they're the same but
they're different okay you're not going
to learn everything about your disease
from just type 1 information or even
just type 2 information but type 3 is
really going to help you
I'm sorry I have a duplicate in there um
so on that type 3 information uh appears
I love this quote from a peer Levy who's
a philosopher a cultural theorist and a
media scholar at the University of
Ottawa and he wrote many years ago in
196 1997 sorry no one knows everything
everyone knows something all knowledge
resides in Networks
and I know I'm talking to a technical
audience but he wasn't talking about
technical networks like computer
networks he was talking about networks
of people
but it does apply to the computer
network of course as well
so we have a shifting Paradigm in
healthcare because of the
Global access to information uh type 1
type 2 and type 3 information by the way
um we we have a shifting Paradigm in
healthcare the traditional Healthcare
Paradigm and you still see it today
because we haven't made this transition
yet is information asymmetry
it's the physician is an oracle The
Physician is the font of all knowledge
and Physicians are very comfortable with
this but I would say and I do say that
that for Physicians it's kind of a
burden because when I talk to groups of
Physicians I say okay we're just among
friends here and there are a thousand
people there whatever how many of you
know everything there is to know about
your field of Medicine
and people have this uncomfortable laugh
right because they know that they can't
know everything
so so it's impossible for us to do this
but at the same time we act as if we
know everything we act like the
know-it-all that everybody hated in
school right we act like that and this
is what we're comfortable with but
that's kind of living a lie
and we need to we need to rethink that
and we have to rethink it because people
have access to this information we don't
have a lot on knowledge anymore
so we need to move to information
symmetry where the physician and the
patient are partners and rather than
feeling threatened about this we should
feel liberated by that because all of a
sudden we don't have to live this lie
anymore
and we can go back to being healers
again I mean we didn't go into health
care because we wanted to be the
know-it-all at least most of us did we
really wanted to help people with our
knowledge and it's that's not about
being a know-it-all it's about the more
human aspects of Health Care
one of our colleagues Mark Phantom
Hutchins who is an informatics colleague
in Texas although she just recently
retired uh Mark when I showed her this
she said you know what Danny you're not
talking about power asymmetry
and power asymmetry is a huge systemic
issue that we have
and and that is that imagine the patient
who walks into
the hallowed Halls of OHSU right and
everything is clean and sparkly and
white and uh and they just feel like
they have to like stay in their boxes as
a patient and not question things and
and they they have to sort of respect
the hierarchy
um and that is a problem and in fact
it's more of a problem for people of
color or people who have been
historically discriminated against okay
imagine uh imagine African-American
coming to a place where almost
everybody's white except for the lower
level staff right and that's not good
and that's going to make people even
more uncomfortable and create more of a
challenge because power asymmetry is a
big problem because we can't get things
done in in the uh industrial World okay
this leads to all kinds of problems that
Toyota first famously identified
um and in healthcare this leads to
problems too and I'm not even talking
about patients if you look at what's the
Dynamics of surgical teams for example
when people are afraid to raise their
hand and say hey I think there's a
problem here that's why we have time
outs and things like that and we're
trying to change this culture in
healthcare but patients are part of this
uh this this hierarchy and we need to be
more collaborative
so one of the things we can do
as Healthcare professionals is we can
ask our patients you know we're really
good about asking patients hey do you
smoke and how much you're drinking now
bill bill
um so so we're good about patients
asking patients that and their sexual
history and drugs and and all this stuff
and you exercise but but we should be
asking them too where do they get their
health information
because we know from the previous data
that's going to change their their
behaviors
um because they're going to act on that
information and if they're not telling
us about it that's going to be a problem
maybe that's why they're not taking
their medicines maybe that's why they're
not going to the specialist we refer
things here so by asking patients uh
that says to patients oh this guy's cool
with it or this This Woman's cool with
it this doctor's cool with it the point
is is that now I'm Not Afraid about this
it you know they say you know some
patients are worried if I bring this up
my doctor is going to say I want to hear
about that stuff right outside of my
office because I own that information
and that leads to honest disclosures
which is of course an important part of
a trusting relationship
um and we need transparency in every
aspect of Health Care and Society in
general I just was watching the news
this morning as I was getting ready and
I understand that uh President Obama now
is pushing uh proposal to make sure that
there are no hidden charges on any
things that we uh when we buy theater
tickets or we uh you know sign up we
make reservations at a hotel no more
hidden charges it needs to be more
transparent well what about Health Care
Health Care is the worst right you have
no idea what things are going to cost
when you go into Healthcare you get a
doctor's appointment you get these bills
because all of us have a deductible I
mean you know I mean gone are the days
where you have like no deductible so
everyone's paying out of pocket and I
remember when my kids first got their
own health insurance they said dad why
am I having to pay you know 500 for
these lab tests and I look at them they
didn't even need the lab test but but
nobody asked right so we need more
transparency and there's a number of
things we need transparency and we need
transparency of data so all the
information about you which now through
Federal Regulation and the society
promoted this you know data transparency
is is coming it's here it's uh it's
gonna get better uh charges what are
things going to cost by the way Health
Care charges Healthcare charges
Healthcare expenses a leading cause of
bankruptcy the leading cause of
bankruptcy in the U.S that's ridiculous
and in other countries so I've traveled
a lot in China
um in China there's a lot of Health Care
is covered but if you've got forbid get
diagnosed with cancer this will actually
bankrupt your entire family I mean
that's how bad it is because you can't
get those medications paid for and then
there's quality
right there's no transference about
quality I mean it's kind of absurd you
know if you come to me as a doctor and
you have whatever problem let's say you
hurt your hip or something and you get a
procedure done and you see a specialist
you're going to say who should I see and
I'm going to say oh see doctor so and so
and then you should say you know how do
you know Dr so-and-so is good
and I'll say oh because I've sent a lot
of patience to her and nobody's
complaining or uh you know I play golf
with her every once in a while and she
seems like night praying this person we
have no information about quality of
outcomes right nor do we have uh say
information about satisfaction so those
those are the things that I think we
need more transparency in
uh
how can we Foster uh collaboration with
patients the next thing I want to talk
about is Communications and um so I'm
going to mention a number of things that
relate to Communications here don't take
too long but but um we need
multi-channel communication
we cannot just focus on the time we have
in the office and I'll come back to that
later we need to provide access for
example to electronic messaging like
email right or secure messaging and as
Bill know I was a an early Pioneer in
this space I co-authored the very first
guidelines on using email with patients
in 1998
and still doctors say oh I'm not
changing I'm not exchanging email with
citations but it's huge it improves
access it's more convenient it avoiding
the tyranny of the urgent
shared decision making and other
Communications issue leads to reduced
anxiety faster recovery and improved
adherence with and satisfaction to the
care plan we need to be culturally
insensitive in our Communications we
need to increase Health Equity and
respect which improves trust and
adherence and we need to have better EHR
etiquette and I think I have a slide
about that I'm probably going to just
get through quickly but but how we use
that EHR and Bill over here uh and uh
and and me too we were early Pioneers in
the use of ehrs and practices right and
we had to fight Upstream because our
colleagues said oh I'm not bringing a
computer into our offices I'm sure Bill
remembers this well
um and and we had we we did this right
in the early days but what's happened
now is that first of all ehrs are often
uh
often if the doctors working for the EHR
rather than EHR working for the doctors
which is not the way we designed things
many years ago
um secondly we have still not really
figured out how to appropriately use
this technology in the offices and there
is a good way and a bad way to use this
um I'll leave it at that
um let's skip through this the interest
of time but there's there's some things
that I reference uh a number of the
features of electronic uh electron
communication with patients but it's
it's really important patients benefit
from this a lot and doctors benefit from
this a lot too once they've embraced it
I mean think about your life if you only
had to talk to people on the phone or
see people face to face I know my kids
who are now you know in their late 20s
they never want to talk to people face
to face they only want to use electronic
communication of various kinds right so
we need to we need to appreciate that
fact and it really is a way that we can
take care of patients using this
technology because we're too busy
there's a huge line of patients waiting
to see us it takes months to get to see
a doctor in many practices unless it's
an emergency room right so we need to
fix those problems and in mental health
as you know it's even worse in most
places I assume that's true here too
most place I've been to yeah it's
impossible to see a psychiatrist and
it's tough to see a therapist too
um so there are guidelines about how to
use electronic health records in the
office and since uh only one of you is
currently using an EHR right I assume
you're not you know you know only one of
these in the room is using an EHR now I
won't go through this but when we
distribute the um uh the slides you can
see this better but there are rules
trust me practice this way it's much
better for patients and much better for
the doctor but I think the one thing I
would take away from this is recognize
that we can't
we need to be human in the office that's
why the acronym for the first part is
human we need to be human in the office
we need to respect that we can't be
always interacting with that computer
and not connecting with our patient
you know I mean the worst thing is is
you know we got this computer screen
maybe turned away it usually turned away
from the patient they can't see what
we're doing and we type in a way looking
at the screen or a keyboard or both and
we're not looking at the patient
I mean you know I mean literally this
stuff happens patients saying oh yeah my
husband beats me and I tell you how much
does he beat you and you know just
really get injured I mean this is the
kind of stuff that goes on we're losing
compassion we need to follow better
rules about that and we need to
appreciate the fact that when we use an
EHR it's not just a patient in the
doctor in the room there is a third
party and we can't ignore it and we
can't pay too much attention to it we
need to make that part of the
conversation and that can be a useful
part of the conversation
for example turn this patient should be
watching what you're doing on the screen
the patient should be able to look at
the date their own data
um show you know this is what happened
when you stop taking your blood pressure
medicine look at what happened to your
blood pressure measurements right we can
show them this information in the office
and that can be a very effective tool I
write my notes with the patients there
using dictation and patients love them
right transparency
all right shared decision making
critically important as I mentioned to
you
um There are rules for how you do shared
decision making This Acronym which is
share is is from the agency for
healthcare research and quality and I I
won't go through with this audience but
I will tell you that we need to be doing
a better job of this because as I
mentioned this leads to improved
satisfaction patients following the plan
because they co-develop the plan and
better outcomes
it's like we're doing that
um I said this
uh next let's talk about convenience
Okay the third of those three areas I
want to talk about
um so how many of you stand in line to
withdraw money from your bank
I gotta be honest with you when I'm
talking to people and you may be some of
those people uh we say wait who would
ever
that never happened right that's not a
thing but it is a thing people used to
do that it's it's incredible to think
about that today technology has totally
changed that another example how many of
you make routine Airline reservations by
talking to a travel agent no
that's a thing too but the travel
agencies are closing because we disinter
mediated them using technology
so why is Healthcare
so problematic because this is what
happens when you call my office or your
office this is crazy right
so this is we make it very difficult we
want patients to keep their appointments
we want patients to fill their medicines
and blah blah blah so this is a survey
this is a decade old admittedly but we
they um they ask patients people who had
seen a doctor in the past year so it's
not like you know people who are 20
years old and haven't seen a doctor and
don't understand ask them
um uh uh how many of these things would
be important to you okay making your
appointments online and it's over 50
percent
making payments and seeing your bill
online is 50 looking at costs online
sending email it's all high proportions
right and then they ask the same people
how many of you can do those today in
your doctor's office
and not surprising the bars are much
lower
now because of Federal Regulation I know
that the Bottom bar has moved up
somewhat but we're still challenging
some of these other areas and again the
whole idea of Technology just where I
showed you in the other slide it can't
reduce barriers it can reduce friction
in these transactions and don't we want
patients to get their care
so this is a huge opportunity I don't
look at it as a failure I look at as an
opportunity because I'm an optimist
um all right next topic would you like a
visit with this Healthcare
okay visits so two axes on the board
here the horizontal axis is diagnose and
treated on the left and prevent and
maintain on the right the vertical axis
is physical resources at the bottom and
virtual resources at the top
where do we spend all of our time and
attention and money
in healthcare today in the U.S
right every time you see a chart like
that the answer is always we're starting
the bottom left okay and that's the most
expensive plot and by the way
and in the upper right is the least
expensive quadrant but this is where
we're focused right now
and if we move to the upper right we get
to change that upper upper right we need
to we can change the horizontal axis to
Health Care Moving from Health Care to
health
many people say we have a sick care
system and not a Health Care system or
it's actually not really a system at all
and we move from physical resources and
virtual resources to the hospital
to the home and even everywhere anywhere
at any time
there are many things that are driving
this a lot of those the things that we
talked about earlier
so this is better for all stakeholders
and the best example of this oh sorry
I'm going to show you this first sorry
uh this this is an example of why this
is important okay this is a a graphic
that was designed by a designer who has
Parkinson's disease she lives in Sweden
her name is Sarah rigora
and Sarah
put together this this image and let me
just explain it to you what looks like a
big blue box is actually a lot of little
blue dots
and each one of the dots in that box
represents an hour in her life in a year
and uh and there's one little tiny red
dot way up in the top row and this is a
magnified image that you see in the
middle and she says to manage her
Parkinson's these Sarah rigorous spends
one hour in neurologic health care and
8765 hours in self-care per year
even our sickest patients and I've done
the math on this patients who feel like
they're in the hospital or the ER or
some special assumes every freaking day
it seems like
um I go through and I do the math and
they're still taking care of themselves
in some way at home with their
caregivers most of the time
so we need to appreciate this fact
okay Health happens between visits
parenthetically I used to work for a
company uh in the early days of that
company
um that was based in Portland
interestingly enough called conversa
health and we adopted this as our slogan
for the company or tagline for the
company Health happens between visits
the uh the the the pandemic that we just
went through has helped accelerate some
of this thinking
because all of a sudden we realize that
we can't be bringing people to the
office anymore just like you don't even
bring people into your division anymore
your Department's our department anymore
as much and because this is to happen to
businesses but really happen in health
care it just wasn't safe people didn't
want to come in we didn't want them here
right
so so that that helped accelerate this
idea that back when I worked at Cisco we
were pushing this idea and this is this
is 12 years ago okay and we were pushing
Telehealth and nobody was budgeting but
what happened in the pandemic is that
all of a sudden there was reimbursement
available for this always follow the
money so if any of you get out of your
informatics careers and you want to go
into business okay you got to follow
that money think about who's going to
pay for this Innovation that you're
developing
at any rate and I am well and I don't
have any I I shouldn't say that I do
have a connection with the Amwell
because Converse to healthcare acquired
by Amwell so I am a shareholder of them
well but that's just an example as you
know there are many companies that are
doing Telehealth right now and there's a
lot more Telehealth taking place and my
patients have not used to this they say
Dr Sears why do I have to come in to see
you I can just do a telemedicine visit
with you yes but you know there are
limitations there are some things I
can't do right right I won't graphically
describe things we can't do but there
are many of them that we can't do that
way however keep this in mind we're
going to come back to this as an
important concept
so now
I'm going to flip over a little bit and
we're going to talk I talked about those
three things that contr that patients
need in order to create a more engaged
in their health now I'm going to talk
about participatory medicine a little
bit
okay participatory medicine which I'm
going to explain in a minute is uh is
something that is fully supported by
medical informatics and this is a really
important thing not that patients and
doctors can't be collaborating and so on
without but the technology really is
important support for this and this is
what I really want to spend the rest of
my time talking about
so let me give you several examples of
this that I think we should be thinking
about
okay one is patient generated Health
Data
patient generated Health Data so that
means not data that comes out of the
instruments in at OHSU or what happens
when we interact with you in the office
but this is stuff that you're doing on
your own right
and there are all kinds of different
things that you might do on your own
when you're at home or not in the office
okay it could be activity levels it
could be it could be symptoms it could
be biometric data everyone always jumps
to the biometric data because that's
cool and sexy right but but
and it is cool right but it's blood
pressures right it's it's weights it's
uh it's pulses it's uh glucose
measurements there's so much stuff but
there's even more as we'll talk about in
a minute medication effects medication
adherence all that stuff is patient
generated Health Data
um there are mobile applications all
this stuff and this is from uh the
office the national coordinator for
health I.T
um so all these different examples
there's quantitative there's qualitative
data there is biometric data there's
self-testing data so that's a really
interesting thing too right which is
that you know it's been a long time now
very decades right where people can do a
pregnancy test at home right okay that's
right it's not even cool anymore right
but what happened in the pandemic right
all of a sudden everybody's got these
test kits they're testing for covet at
home and now there are way more covet
tests being done at home than there are
being done in healthcare facilities okay
that's pretty dramatic right so there's
a lot of testing that takes place you
can test for STIs that's sexually
transmitted infections at home you can
test for HIV at home you can test for uh
all kinds of things you also people
ordering their genomic panels at home
she was really a great uh amount of
stuff
then the next issue is requested versus
unrequest data so let me tell you what I
mean by that well let's say I'm we're
following you hypothetically for high
blood pressure
and so one example would be that I say
to what's your name immersion
so I say I'm ready Hey listen we're
making this blood pressure medication
change I want you to send me some blood
pressure measurements over the next few
weeks in order to read this any few
measurements that's requested data I'm
expecting that and I know what to do
with that
another example what's your name now
Matt decides that it'd be really cool
idea to send me every day all of his
activity information
okay very different examples right one
I'm requesting one I'm not and let's say
you're instead of activity let's suppose
it's your blood pressure did it okay
what happens if I'm not expecting it
right and what what happens if there's
some elevated blood pressure
measurements or very low blood pressure
vitamins who's monitoring that stuff so
that's another issue too
there's physician monitoring who
monitors it within a practice or
liability issues to think about
pre-processing and filtering up the data
data so if you send me your activity
information totally unfiltered right I
don't want that but if I have a system
that's looking through this and and
finding Trends and identifying things
that are important that might be more
useful to me how do we incorporate that
into the record uh accuracy of the data
and follow-up testing so that's what we
often don't think about so an end here I
talk to Engineers all the time work for
them okay Engineers view of the world is
more data is always better
okay but if you're a doctor the Nuance
there is not quite true because the
problem is in biology unless it's
perfect data more biology and more
information is not always big because
you get false positives you get things
that need follow-up and the follow-up by
the way is going to fall to the
Physicians right we've got to follow up
we may have to do expensive or painful
things uh due to risky things to you in
order to get more more data even though
you shouldn't have had that testing in
the first place perhaps
um and then there's patient anxiety when
they get data you may you be doing this
and you're Gathering the data you say oh
my God I'm kind of stressed out and this
happens all the time to me in my
practice patients get their data at home
and they're freaked out you know they
say oh my God my blood pressure
Okay so these areas are areas where
informatics is really important okay
probably more of them too but I
highlighted a few things so looking at
the different data types how do we
acquire them
looking at how we pre-process and filter
that data this is a really good
informatics issue right how do you
identify these Trends and the outliers
and so on really good uh science
questions there incorporation to the
record probably I would have highlighted
except now we actually have technology
to do that we have the fire standard
that allows that to happen we just don't
have policies that Healthcare
organizations and practices that allow
that to be uploaded most of the time
all right
I would say to you that since we're
moving to that upper right hand quadrant
we're doing things like Telehealth and
remote care of various kinds whether
it's synchronous or asynchronous
we need this stuff more than ever before
because how can I have a follow-up with
you and just ask you questions and look
at you on the screen for example and and
not have any data I need some data so I
can make decisions a lot of what we do
as doctors is we're looking at data
looking at dashboards of data
all right Next Step topic
technology tools support collaboration
what I mean by that well think about the
Google Suite of applications all the
things you use when you're collaborating
using Google or using Microsoft teams I
don't know what you guys use here what
do you use teams sorry about that yeah
Beth Israel ridiculous does too and I
can hate it but but that's teams and
then there's slack which the cool people
use okay slack is great too
the time and uh you know all kinds of
other platforms
so before we're talking about Healthcare
right
so we're talking about Healthcare
collaboration between the patient and
the healthcare professional
well we have a collaboration platform
there too it's the patient portal
okay this is my chart it's not
advertisement for my chart but but my
chart is the best example
um so I helped develop one of the
nation's first patient portals back I
won't even tell you how long ago it was
uh but this went live and this is called
patient site and and so
what do I mean this is a collaboration
platform well this is the URL for it you
don't need that what are the elements
what makes it a collaboration platform
and this is any patient portal
um so first of all it has messaging
messaging it's secure it's automatically
routed to people who can best take care
of it and it can be uh you can assign
tests
next it has Services remember we talked
about those online services and reducing
friction and so on so patient could get
prescription refills make their
appointments see their get referrals and
view their bill
and then there's education people can
search for information they can be
prescribed information by their health
care professional right patients can
search through selected links and so on
but the coolest thing is getting to this
type 2 information which is that
patients can see their records online
through patient portals in a secure way
they can look at their record they can
look at all their system records
upcoming appointments medications
problems and their notes now too
there's a whole lot to talk about in the
patient portal so I won't be able to
talk about today but but this is really
exciting the fact that patients actually
have information to detailed information
about their own health in our
institution we tell patients before you
come for your next visit review the
notes from your recent visits so you can
talk about those things okay I ask my
patients do that all the time so um so
here are the elements of collaboration
we talked about the elements that
patients need to be engaged in their
health and we're hitting on all of them
through this collaboration platform
right it's information it's
communication it's convenience
all right the impact of a tool like this
is extraordinary so after we went live
with this my patients were all using the
patient portal I sent a message asking
them you know just tell me what you
think about this this platform uh in
general and uh and what does it mean to
you and so one person this was actually
the guy who later became my collaborator
be patient Dave he sent this message
this is too cool it's almost silly that
things can be this easy I am having a
very good patient slash customer
experience so far
so it was great that he loved it but the
important thing is that what was
important to him is that all of a sudden
he was treated like a customer he said
look I'm in my 50s I've been in the
healthcare system for over 50 years and
never have I been treated like a
customer where people are trying to make
it easier for me to do that
um so that was important for him on the
other hand this this is a guy although
only 61 retired Minister who was
crippled with some kind of weird chronic
pain syndrome used to walk her and so on
he said I have a lot of medical issues
this system has left me feeling
comfortable and in good hands otherwise
I would feel as cold
even alone as the lifeless Tree in my
front yard in the deepest of winter I'm
in Boston remember Winters are bad
um so that had a huge affect of
importance to him this was this was a
Lifeline for him really
so the next area I want to talk about is
helping patients decide and act
okay so
um decision aids for patients in the
context of patient care so
anybody who's been through bills
teaching understands that there's such a
thing as clinical decision support which
helps Healthcare professionals take
better care of patients right using the
information and he and I have built lots
of systems that do that kind of stuff
and that's important
but also important are tools that
patients that we can use with patients
will return the screen to them and
there's a a way that patients can engage
in this conversation as well so that's
important and that's an informatics
project
patient facing clinical decision support
is another one
so tools that patients can use on their
own now it could be you know let's say
we're going to have a breast cancer
screening conversation with with a woman
who's in her 40s
um I might say okay I'm going to turn
the screen to you we're going to launch
this program and you're going to go
through this interactive tool okay
that's one way to do it but what the
other way to do it is at home right
there's a 50 year old man uh and I want
to teach him about prostate cancer
screening and help him come to a
decision about whether to have a PSA
test
um do this at home before you come in
and then we can talk about the results
okay so patient-facing clinical
Association support another important
informatics thing and then allowing
patients to and sending alerts to
patients
so does anyone find it really bizarre
that the patient
so so it were as Healthcare
professionals we're getting alerts about
things oh so and so is doing for
mammogram this person is due for a
pneumococcal vaccine whatever all these
things but we only get them when the
patient is in the room with us or when
we actually look at their record
but why is it that we just don't send
these things directly to our patients
right and next allows them to take
action on those things
again these are informatics projects and
we can we can create these interventions
and we can study them
I have to talk about AI right we're here
talking about technology so what about
Ai and participatory medicine well
this can help
this can help patients search for and
interpret health information that they
find because there's all these health
information websites right if we can
trust the AI agents and create a
dedicated AI to do it you know and
they're not going to do these weird uh
hallucinations which are really
confabulations right but but but then
they can really help patients understand
the more acid information that's out
there but in addition it can help them
understand and interpret their test
results and the medical notes so we've
given patients access to the whole
medical record but how do they
understand what's there
somebody's still going to help them
understand that and that's where I think
AI can play an important role
automated first-year responses to
Patient messages on a patient portal
most doctors in this country are fed up
with messages not that many of them
liked it in the first place but they
don't want more messages from patients
because those got a lot worse during the
pandemic and we've got to figure out
ways to help them with that and one way
we can do this is by hiring people in
the practice to answer messages but we
could maybe come before that before we
get to the human personnel which are
expensive we could create AI agents who
can do this
that can do this I shouldn't say who
um we can facilitate convenience
transactions you know let patients know
oh we think you're due for an
appointment with so and so uh do you
want me to make this appointment for you
why can't we have those kind of Amazon
like agents right that that can do these
things for us
um and self-monitoring of their health
information for all sources so all of us
have information in different places you
know I've got a medical record at my
cardiologist's office I got one of my
primary care doctor's office I got the
pharmacy record I got my health data
from Apple Health all this stuff why
can't I have an agent that's
continuously monitoring this and giving
me suggestions and letting me know when
I should receive care
we don't have such things for the
healthcare professionals either but
patients need this also
all right so it's collaboration with so
these are some of the informatics things
that I think that we can do to support
uh participatory health care so the
collaboration leads to benefits it leads
to improve reduced costs improve
satisfaction and better outcomes so that
we achieve what has been called the
triple aim I don't know if you've heard
that term before uh but that triple that
is the Triple A and because it actually
can improve satisfaction for both
patients and Physicians it'll help us it
helps us achieve what has been called
the quadruple aim
one of my mentors and someone that a
colleague of Bill and mine uh Warner
slack who's since been deceased Warner
wrote the largest and least utilized
Healthcare Resource is the patient
now what's interesting about this is
that Warner wrote this in 1976
and if that Warner did his first
informatics work at the University of
Wisconsin in the 60s where he sat
patients down in front of a computer to
get a medical history
60s right so he's definitely a friend
and Mentor he really inspired me in a
lot of my work
so I'm winding down here you know we
mentioned the society for participatory
medicine we work in a lot of different
areas we invite you to check us out join
us whatever
um
participatory medicine is a movement in
which patients and Health Care
Professionals actively and collaborate
and encourage one another so this is
mutuality to it it's not just about
patient power it's about the patients
and the healthcare professionals and
each of us pushing the other to the NRA
games
as full Partners in healthcare
and I'm going to just flip through this
real quickly because I've outlined the
important areas
we we have a Manifesto a set of core
principles and since I can't read it on
the screen there
um to uh and this came out of work that
we we did at conferences where we
actually brought a lot of people
together to uh discuss what these things
were and the principles are sharing and
listening respect one another share
information responsibly
um promote curiosity and be a team
Builder
so bringing this back to informatics for
a second
um
I don't know how many of you work in
networking or access or anything like
this but there's this concept called The
Last Mile
and when you're talking about networking
and and Telecommunications okay what the
last mile means is that
you have to sort of deal with all this
infrastructure over here though the
backbone of the the internet or the
telecommunication Network and then
there's sort of the middle mile which is
the fiber transport and so on that's
connecting this to this but the hardest
part is getting this into patients homes
okay getting patients into right
patients homes and that is called The
Last Mile and that's kind of what
participatory medicine is it's really
you know there's some things we can
control and sometimes we can't control
but when patients enter the Health Care
System that's what uh what we do
so we have a changing nature of the
relationship we're moving from
information asymmetry to information
symmetry we're moving from patients
being passive recipients of Health Care
to the active Partners we're moving from
paternalism to participation and finally
we're moving from patients from being a
patient physician relationship to also
being a consumer provider relationship
so to summarize I think despite the
challenges we have in healthcare today
we have huge opportunities
so number one reimagining patient care
is a collaboration can help us transform
our Health Care system with the patient
at the center
number two
medical informatics provides technology
tools and Innovations that's technology
tools and innovations that support this
important transformation
I thank you for your attention I welcome
your questions from the audience members
virtually and in the room and I'm happy
to communicate with you outside as well
thanks
thank you
how do we get people to yeah so let me
just um ask uh since we can't really see
the the chat real well I don't know if
anything's typed there but um people how
do I do that is there something I need
to do no no but people uh just unmute
themselves and just send any questions
that they have I know we're about at the
hour but we have a few minutes for
questions
by the way this is a book now in the
lower left hand corner let patients help
a short book that Dave and I wrote
together
all right I'm going to end that and take
this out so we can
I see that that Kate has turned her
videos
hey hey you can't see me I guess huh
I can see you
um okay thank you for your wonderful
talk Danny
um it reminds me all the troubles with
technology reminds me of the time when I
followed you in Grand rounds and people
are asking you how to fix their pager so
that was that was that was really good
um the question I have is the one that I
care about is education uh the education
of the patient education of the doctor
so how do you balance this out you know
some patients really do want to be the
know-it-all
and they don't have the education for
example that you've had
so how would you it's kind of like where
I've been thinking a lot about in terms
of you know who who who has the
education in order to provide the advice
yeah um so the question Kate asked is an
interesting one which is about you know
patients who just sort of feel like they
know everything and they don't
understand the fact that you have
expertise there too and and I think that
you know this is why at the society at
least we kind of focus on educating
patients as well as educating physicians
in fact just to put another plug-in on
Friday when we have this Creative
Learning exchange here at the Robertson
Life Sciences Center
um
um you know we we will have patience in
the room as well as Healthcare
professionals okay and and what we need
to convey is this idea that
yes the doctor isn't or I don't want to
say the doctor the health care
professional is an expert in health care
and in their area of medicine but the
patient is an expert in themselves and
their own symptoms and their own body
and I think it's not that we have to
stick to our swim Lanes it's about
learning how to dance maybe that's a
better way to put it and there's always
going to be friction because you know as
you said some patients are not okay with
that and they don't respect you know any
of the education that we have education
experience and so on but on the other
hand the same thing is true in the
opposite way too which is that we often
don't respect what the patients bringing
to the table
so this is like learning to dance and
another one of my mentors Tom Tom Del
Banco uses that expression which I think
is a good one
um it's learning to dance and we're not
always going to quite get it right but
we've got to continue to work at it and
I think to the extent that we can
educate
Health Care Professionals early in their
education
and we can educate patients before they
need to be patients when they're in
middle school that's what we really want
to do
so I know it's not a perfect answer I
don't have all the answers
I still have tension with my patients
sometimes too yeah yeah great thanks for
questioning any other
questions I I will also mention that
Faraz who's on the WebEx here is the MC
for our event uh on on Friday and thank
you for us for doing that
of course
any other questions or comments
hi this is Karen Eden and hi Karen what
hi so one of the projects we have going
right now is that we send a message to
patients inviting them to use our breast
cancer screening risk tool and to my
chart so we send it through the portal
and the clinicians have have been very
supportive of this idea but one of the
challenges we had was figuring out a way
to succinctly bring the information back
to the clinician in some kind of note
and I noticed the importance of patient
generated data so I just don't we don't
want to overwhelm the clinician with
information but do you have any ideas
about how we can provide that in a way
that is concise and sustained but it
lets the clinician know more about
yourself there and the things that
they're doing
yeah
um thanks for the question Karen I think
that's a really important project you're
doing and I know that there's a
researcher Maura Schoenberg in my
division at uh That official Deaconess
who's also involved in a project like
that at any rate um yeah I I think that
the way that I would think about that is
ideally and again you may be limited by
the technology but I think at the very
least
there should be a note so a note that
comes out of that that goes into the
record that summarizes the results of
this decision support tool that the
patients went through and then you may
need to let clinicians know that that
note exists now ideally that node is an
interactive note not just a PDF document
so the next stage would be to make it
interactive so the doctor could click on
something and see a dashboard that shows
that why the patient came out this way
so I I think that's probably the way to
do it but of course we don't want to
have doctors have to log into a
different website or something to get
that information
thanks for the question no I agree thank
you so much great presentation
thank you Karen great well we're we're
at about an hour so
um I think and another and people may
have other meetings so um thank you
again Danny for um enlightening us with
your talk and
um it was a great discussion thank you
thank you feel free to email me later if
you have any other questions or comments
and come on Friday
that okay